perspiration without inspiration is a
nightmare but inspiration without
perspiration is a daydream so how do you
do it how do you come with the plan how
do you make that vision a reality I'm
gonna give you three ways to do it if
there's any level of romance left in
this room about your idea
I'd like to suffocate it because I think
the actual situation is what you
actually do with it rise and shine it's
in spresso time what's that believed
nation it's Evan my one word is believe
and I believe in you I believe you have
Michael Jordan level talent at something
and I want you to find it embrace it and
use it to make a difference in the world
so let's start your day off right grab
your coffee and sip on today's message
act with a vision over to you go or
Gopal das Thomas Alva Edison once made a
very nice statement he said genius is 1%
inspiration and 99% perspiration
we may have an inspiration in our heart
but 1% strong burning Inferno of an
inspiration but unless that inspiration
is put into action
dedicated committed hard work that 99%
perspiration we are not going to be able
to achieve what we want to achieve and
so also when we talk about dealing with
our bad habits success is 1% inspiration
and 99% perspiration
we need that inspiration but based on
the foundation of that inspiration we
have to put on dedicated committed hard
work that 99% perspiration what's
amazing is that 99% perspiration is
based on the foundation of that 1%
inspiration if the foundation of a
building is in place the very first
thing that we make when it comes to
a structure a house a beautiful edifice
or a mansion is we put the foundation in
place if the foundation is in place if
it's strong and robust then all the
building block is the bricks the cement
the mortar the steel can go on and form
a beautiful structure for us to live in
for us to dwell in and so also that 1%
inspiration is the foundation of that
99% perspiration imagine if you're very
inspired to change if you're very
inspired to give up some of your bad
habits but you don't put that hard work
that 99% perspiration what good is that
inspiration or imagine if you keep
putting 99% of perspiration that hard
work that effort the dedicated
commitment but if you don't have that
inspiration to do it in the right
direction and sustain it and get it a
higher shelf life what good is that hard
work and perspiration therefore success
comes by a balance of the two
inspiration which acts as the foundation
and perspiration which acts as the
building blocks to build upon that
foundation I once read a very
interesting Japanese proverb it said
action without vision is a nightmare if
you simply keep acting without having
the right vision the result is a
nightmare and it said vision without
action is a daydream if you simply have
a vision and you don't act upon it all
you have as a result is a daydream I
have rephrased it for our discussion
here today perspiration without
inspiration is a nightmare but
inspiration without perspiration is a
daydream
sorry big believer that planners need to
do more and doers need to plan more I
think generally as entrepreneurs we like
to be visionaries like to be big
thinkers we we have a plan for how the
world is going to change and our role
and and how exciting that can be to have
the
huge impact but we get so lost in our
head because it's fun it's great to
imagine the problem solved we love
solving puzzles we love that mental
exercise but then you actually have to
do it it's great that you figured it all
out in your head but now you actually
have to go and execute and I don't know
if I'm at 99% to 1% personally but I'm
I'm pretty close to it you might think
that I talk a lot and there's a lot of
vision coming out but most of my day is
spent not not thinking and planning but
doing executing how do I get thousands
of videos up because I'm working because
I'm doing it and every now and then I'll
adjust and I'll see if that works for me
the plan is still working if I still
like it or not I don't think you can do
the same thing forever and always
because you will change as a human so
you need to adjust your schedule
accordingly but most of my time is not
spent on strategy most of my time is
spent doing and if you look at
successful entrepreneurs or anybody
anybody anybody anybody anybody who's
had massive success they're not spending
all this time in their head they're
spending time actually executing those
ideas and so it's great to be the
visionary it's a lot of fun it's
mentally stimulating but you have to do
the work so how do you do it how do you
come with the plan how do you make that
vision a reality I'm gonna give you
three ways to do it
number one is set a vision so you have
to have a clear vision of what you want
to accomplish it doesn't have to be a
specific goal but you have to have like
you have a sense of purpose why are you
here what are you doing for me I want to
solve the world's biggest problem
untapped human potential all of the work
that I do is geared towards a quater
make a youtube channel why do I make
videos every single day because I think
the environment and the habits that
people have does a lot to actually shift
their mindset their perspectives and
thereby their actions I think the more
you hang around successful people doing
big things it's gonna shake you I want
to shake you it's what I want to do I
wanna I want to shake you from your
current environment from the people
around you I want to introduce new
people new ideas bigger thinking into
your environment that's why I make these
videos every single day for you it's the
best way that I know how on how to do it
so you have to start with that vision
what do you try to accomplish why is it
so important to you to is then create a
calendar put in your calendar the things
that will allow you to go off and make
that vision happen if you have a big
vision to change the world and you look
at your calendar and it's not
you the time that we often do it you're
never gonna get there it's great to be
inspired but you have to make sure that
the actions in your calendar will map to
your vision happening as an example when
it came back from a Tony Robbins event
unleash the power within in California
everybody's super inspired and it's
great and rah-rah you're feeling the
emotion it's amazing my default is okay
if I want to do any of these things I
need to adjust my calendar because my
calendar represents what I actually take
action on if I'm not doing it in my
calendar then I just got this high but
I'm not actually taking the action and
so you have to look at your calendar and
see if I did this stuff every day if I
follow it what I put in my calendar will
my vision ultimately happen for me right
now it's making youtube videos doing
books doing interviews that kind of
stuff I look at my calendar consistently
and say if this gets done every week
it's the most likely chance that I will
go and hit my vision and if your
calendar does not map to you're hitting
your vision then you need to adjust your
calendar and number three is review and
adjust what you think will work may not
actually work so you can't just keep the
same calendar the same schedule for the
rest of your life you are not to seem
human being as you were five years ago
even if your vision is the same my
vision has stayed pretty consistent I
want to go out and have a big impact but
what I do how I execute that has changed
over the years I used to think that I
would never write a book that was never
on my to-do list I thought it would not
be helpful and then when I came up with
your one word I thought it actually
worked better as a book than as a video
when I came up with the top ten rules of
success I thought of if I opened my book
and I read one page a day if I could use
that as a habit myself and learn from it
then I could inspire this as well and I
read that book every single morning what
you end up planning may not actually
happen one because the plans don't work
and two because you you change you get
other interests you want to do something
else I may not be on YouTube forever
right I don't plan to or there's gonna
be something else that comes up when I
abandon YouTube and go for that that
will happen at some point and so just
being locked into the same schedule
forever and ever
especially as an entrepreneur sucks
because we love variety because we love
creativity because we want to do new
things because as we grow and evolve we
want to bring that into our business we
want what our life looks like to be
reflection of who we are and the more
you let the chains of success
prevent you from doing something else
doing a new change then you will not be
happy and so you need a constant review
and evaluation of your schedule and is
it I'll still allowing you or not to do
the things that will allow you to go off
and help achieve your mission I've got a
really special bonus clip that I think
you're gonna enjoy but before that I
want to know what's the most important
action item that you need to take
towards achieving your mission you got a
big mission big vision what are you
gonna do today to act on it
leave in the comments below when you
write it down it's much more likely to
stick and actually happen so leave it in
the comments thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much love
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso and enjoy the
bonus clip
[Music]
my assistants got a great thing now and
this once in every four months somebody
sends an email saying I've got a huge
startup that I want you to invest in but
you've gotta sign this NDA right which
literally every time gets an email back
that says right and and the reason is
I'm a humongous believer that ideas are
and that executions the game right we've
all got ideas everybody's got ideas
doing ideas we all have here we can
probably sit here for the next two hours
draw them all out record them and
predict the next 78 great startups over
the next nine years and so I think the
thing that is another theme in
entrepreneurship is there is way too
much fodder brought to the idea Hoover
was magic cab three years earlier uber
is not an idea
uber existed it's called magic cab but
the guys that execute it sucked so they
lost so I think you know if there's any
level of romance left in this room about
your idea
I'd like to suffocate it because I think
the actual situation is what you
actually do with it I mean the reality
is reading a book or going to a
conference or having a great
conversation where you get this golden
information that's all fantastic but
what makes mastery is execution on the
ideas not the ideas and so no idea works
unless you're willing to roll up your
sleeves do the practice invest the time
put in the effort do the work I think
we've all observed a lot of people who
they love reading the books they love
showing up at the courses they do all
the online training and nothing ever
changes and they say well you know I
don't know why it doesn't change why my
life doesn't change why my thinking
doesn't change why my performance
doesn't change why my relationships
don't change well it's because ideas
don't work if you don't execute on them
so if you look at the great business
builders you look at any great performer
one thing that makes them great is their
grit one thing that makes them great is
their hunger
to practice one thing that makes them
great is they are willing to sacrifice I
mean yes they're passionate but did you
know the root of the word passion is
suffering you've got to be willing to
suffer for your vision you've got to be
willing to suffer to reach BIW best in
world you've got to be willing to suffer
the ridicule and laughter of your
critics and your cynics to get to a
place called world class time is now
what are you waiting for
you don't need permission you'll need
other people to tell you that you got to
go all in it's all on you now is the
time for you to make up for all the
times in your life where you didn't give
your all where you made excuses where
you cut corners the new you happens now
time to stop being like most people it's
time to stop letting other people
dictate your standards in your vision
most people say they're gonna have a
brand new van when the new year starts
when January comes they're in the gym
they're fired up if you go to the gym in
the beginning of the year you're gonna
see it stacked with people everywhere go
two weeks later you'll see nobody it's
because people get pumped and hyped but
they don't follow through once the
action is bit tougher it's on you it's
your turn to spark your own fire you
don't need someone else tell you to
Sparky on fire tell you what you're
worth what's on you and the new you
begins when you make a decision to go
all-in on what you think about every day
under vision and make it a reality if
you tell yourself a story long enough
you start to believe it don't you
believe it you act like I am Tulsa what
a wail out of handcuffed lightning
though Thunder in jail now you know I'm
bad over the last week I murdered a rock
into the stone hospitalized a brick I'm
so mean I make medicine sick the
fundamental key to success he's it can
take between 18 and 250 four days of
taking action for a new habit to stick
I've created a new course called 250 for
confidence or every single day for 250
four days I will be sending you a video
between 30 seconds and five minutes long
that you start your morning with around
making you feel confident it's
absolutely free check out the link in
the description below to get access